Let's work this out.
What I'm really asking you is the probability of a fair coin "f" given that I observed H.
This has nothing to do with total probability
and all with Bayes Rules, because I'm talking about observations.
The non-normalized probability according to Bayes Rule is obtained as follows:
the probability of observing H for the fair coin is 0.5,
and the probability of having grabbed the fair coin is 0.5 as well.
The non-normalized probability of not F given H, which is the loaded coin,
is probability of H given not f,
which we know to be 0.1--that's the one over here--
times the probability of not picking the fair coin, which is 0.5,
ends up to be 0.05.
When we now normalize, we α = 0.25 + 0.05, which is 0.3.
If we now normalize the 0.25 over here with the 0.3, we get 0.833,
which is the same as 5/6.
That's our posterior probability we hold the fair coin after we observed H.